all right we find ourselves here
yet again it is night three out of four
of the democratic national convention we
have a bunch of speakers we will be
hearing from today including former
president barack obama
i will be hearing from you and your
comments i have
um other memes as i like to say
and we have a whole bunch of different
things going on but it is night three of
four
and the next week will be the rnc
friday is my first pog champs game let
me actually see what is my pog champ
schedule so friday i've got a game
monday and then the following saturday i
guess is
is my schedule but in the meantime we're
going to have all sorts of things
happening
starting at the top of the hour so what
is on the
the schedule for today today we will
have
senator elizabeth warren we will have a
performance
by billy eilish we will have speaker
a house speaker nancy pelosi former
secretary of state hillary clinton
governor tony evers
governor michelle grisham
former congresswoman gabrielle giffords
jennifer hudson will perform
prince royce will perform senator kamala
harris the vice presidential nominee is
going to perform
perform she will be speaking it will be
a performance of sorts
these are all really performances as
they are mostly uh highly choreographed
and then former president barack obama
will be i'm guessing
obama is going last although maybe
senator kamala harris is actually going
last but there will be performances and
speeches
of all kinds starting uh in only
eight minutes only eight minutes to go
uh lola cole is checking in with a super
chat and says how old is david pakman
i'm 22
22 years old and i've been doing the
show for 15 years actually
this sunday is the 15-year anniversary
of the show so
you do the math we also did start to get
a list
of people who will be speaking at the
republican national convention
and it's crazy like it almost seems like
it has to be a joke
um look at this the saint louis
couple who pointed guns at black lives
matter
protesters are going to be speaking at
the republican national convention
my streams of the rnc are going to do
way better than the
dnc right because this this is insane
it's completely insane
the saint louis couple who pointed guns
at black lives matter protesters
the covington they misspelled covington
the covington
teenager captured in a viral
interaction with a native american elder
is going to be speaking at the rnc if
you can imagine something
more insane anti-abortion activist abby
johnson
that seems almost pedestrian compared to
what else is expected so
okay this is that the gun wielding
couple
you can't write this [ __ ] as people are
saying exactly patricia and mark
mccloskey are the st
louis homeowners who gained attention
for wielding guns at protesters
they will be speaking on monday
um also speaking will be covington
high school graduate nicholas sandman
um criminal justice reform advocate
alice johnson
she's the one who who uh was had her
sentence commuted after kim kardashian
told trump about her
um former planned parenthood clinic
director turned anti-abortion activist
will be there
melania trump is speaking a bunch of
trump's kids
former un ambassador nikki haley
senator tim scott they need a black
person there obviously so they're
bringing in tim scott joni ernst
south dakota governor christie gnome
pennsylvania congressional candidate
sean parnell um it's a mess it's a mess
now what i don't know is does anybody
know that the time of day is the rnc
also going to be 9 to 11
i would i would prefer it to be earlier
but i haven't been able to find it if
anybody can
tell me when what's the schedule for
for from the standpoint of the clock
what's the schedule for rnc i don't know
if anybody knows
and in the meantime while i wait for
answers on that uh jacobrattner asks
about my thoughts on the russian news
out of the senate we'll be covering that
on the show tomorrow
and have i had any time to practice
chess i hope you choose to castle early
yeah i've been doing a lot of
now i in addition to my public practice
i've also been doing uh shadow
opposition
research and that's a very very
important thing
um let's see here
um james buccino says hopefully trump's
heart might stop soon due to all the ice
cream and fast food i would never wish
that on anybody
okay so people are saying that it looks
scheduled for 9 to 11.
um ok so i guess it's going to be 9 to
11 next week as well let me see if i can
find something
rnc schedule let's see if i type in 9 to
11
eastern watching the dnc and rnc okay
here we go
um looking for an article
10 to 11 is on abc
fox news this is crazy
this doesn't seem to make it clear i'm
assuming that it's the same schedule 9
to 11
but i guess we don't know we don't know
for sure
okay a lot of people grabbing youtube
memberships commander unnamed lawrence
golden emily swaboda
maths john thompson myra herbstmann
as well as stephen bellgaard all signing
up over on
youtube um also sadman
double08 has grabbed a twitch prime
subscription
if you didn't notice earlier donald
trump seemed to
um almost like endorse q anon i mean
this is really this is really aggressive
stuff take a look at this this was earl
just hours ago
it is this belief that you are secretly
saving the world from this satanic
cult of pedophiles and cannibals does
that sound like something
you are behind well i haven't i
haven't heard that but is that supposed
to be a bad thing or a good thing
right if uh if i can help save the world
from probably it sounds like the q anon
beliefs are all good things
problems i'm willing to do it i'm
willing to put myself out there
and we are actually we're saving the
world from a
left philosophy so then he's saying
i haven't heard it but if that's what
they're saying it doesn't sound bad and
in fact it is what i'm doing that will
destroy
this country and when this country is
gone
the rest of the world would follow right
the rest of the world would follow
there you go so very very poignant
donald trump there as you can see
uh we will be keeping an eye on donald
trump's tweets throughout the evening
uh he did tweet an hour ago welcome back
welcome barack and crooked hillary so
you
see you on the field of battle also
tweeted
uh clips from his own press briefing
earlier
uh an update in terms of subscribers
on youtube we are now expected projected
by socialblade to reach 1 million
youtube subscribers on october 29th
that's the latest update and of course
it's very exciting for me i don't know
that anybody else cares
but it's certainly very very exciting
for me and as i did yesterday
so my my goal is if there are
sort of like i don't know what to call
them if if there are
elements tonight that are not the
primary speeches
or of interest for some other reason
i will probably hear from you guys and
and read messages from you guys via
super chat via twitch etc
and then we'll mute during those periods
and then watch but
that that's sort of the plan it seemed
to work well relatively well yesterday
anyway
and of course if we do get to 50 website
members
or patrons the phone lines via discord
will be blown
wide open we have a new official david
pakman show discord
you can find it at davidpakman.com
discord and
that's the official discord and that's
where we will take phone calls if indeed
we achieve
50 website members and patrons and i'm
going to do you guys a favor
there was someone who signed up
yesterday right after the stream ended
and they weren't counted just for kicks
we're going
to count them as number one okay just
that's a gift
that's a gift from me to you so that is
all
happening very powerfully super chats
continue to come in
your local gp says when brexit happened
the ukip
party pretty much disappeared lost
it's reson d'etre will the same happen
to the david pakman show yes
uh if trump loses very good for the
country
the end of the david pakman show okay so
enjoy it while it lasts
tyler mcclary says nicholas sandman and
st louis gunwavers speaking at the rnc
laura loomer and marjorie taylor green
win primaries republican party has huge
problems regardless of trump remember
down ballot folks
not only that even if trump loses
we still will have 60 million people
that voted for him living in this
country
how do we deal with them you understand
what i'm saying
that's another major problem that we're
going to have to deal with
um oh a lot is happening here new by def
noob by default subscribed with twitch
prime d miller gifted a subscription
uh stephen bellgaard signed up at
joinpackman.com in his new member number
two
sabres man actually vicki tabor tabor
grabbed the soy boy membership sabres
man says democrats should fight for
early voting as much as malen
expanded at least a month it would make
this so much safer absolutely
completely agree with you tam i am has
subscribed
jackson says david i'm a huge fan of
your elements of humor from the
standpoint of entertainment
absolutely i agree with that
cg says you know you just want to watch
billy
johnny minogue says i hope billy eilish
sings bad guy
to someone dressed up as trump that
would be kind of funny that's not a bad
idea
i kind of like the sound of that for
sure um
there was lower viewership on night two
of the convention than night one so i
think
night one there was more of a novelty it
was the first night
but it wasn't the best night two
um i think was better but lower
viewership
and then we will see if my guess is
maybe viewership will build tonight and
then peak
tomorrow night by the way uh rush
limbaugh
as many of you know him did uh quote me
he quoted me from one of the tweets i
sent on
monday i will play that for you just
briefly just to give you a little bit of
a flavor
here it is david pakman political tv
radio show host tweeted someone please
talk me off the ledge
right i want to win the first 22 minutes
of this convention i'm scared can
somebody tell me how great this is or
something can somebody make me feel
better
now can somebody make me feel better he
is he is putting in my mouth i didn't
actually
say that uh but that was uh that was
rush limbaugh
so we talked about that on the podcast
today um hardcore fps says look for the
video of gretchen whitmer talking about
shark week it's hilarious i did see that
um
in fact i guess we have some time let's
see whitmer shark
week see if we can find it here
it's not just shark week is shark week
right
you i have learned about the hat mike
yeah she really really needed a glass of
water during that thing but nobody
helped her out
uh okay the hype train is leaving the
station on twitch with fluffy
leprechauns subscribing with prime it's
happening
um bernie sanders says thoughts on
shapiro saying biden
is a far left radical no idea i don't
watch ben shapiro i have no idea what he
said
and since i don't know it would be weird
to comment on it i want to say thanks to
sean davis who's new member number three
on my website tonight and savannah banks
who is new member number four tonight
very much appreciate that
david r says david my girlfriend is back
in town
and we are ready to watch what can we
expect tonight well
uh i think the most interesting
components tonight are going to be
kamala and barack obama
and we are just moments just moments
from the start there are just
formalities here that are continuing so
we're not
covering those in any particular detail
but we are going to get to this as soon
as the meat starts
the sr conan says if trump loses will
there be any kind of prosecution
i i think people have to forget about
that okay
um i keep getting people asking me will
trump be taken out in handcuffs
this is not a country that arrests
former presidents or charges former
presidents i'm not saying
that it wouldn't be warranted i'm just
saying it
doesn't happen and i don't believe it's
going to happen with donald trump and so
the accountability is making him a
one-term president which is difficult to
do
bill clinton did it to george h.w bush
that's h as in white
um and it's difficult to do
it's just difficult to do so i think
that is the really what we need to be
looking forward to
um joseph van scoy says what will the
republican party look like post
trump i have a video clip up on my
youtube channel from last friday
discussing that so i encourage you to
check that out
um let's let's listen to a little bit of
governor tony evers here
oh no he's done
[Music]
hello my name is terry williams i've
been a republican for all of my adult
life a lifelong republican
okay all right i guess we have a little
bit more time here thanks to jhkjdu
for subscribing over on twitch where we
do have we have not achieved level 5
hype train
for like 10 days which is really sad
thanks to captain murdock for
subscribing with prime
uh charlie says from the standpoint of
tires what's your take in the goodyear
silly business um
you know it's like the right claims to
be against boycotts and then trump is
saying boycott goodyear so it's a little
bit weird for sure
aaron mcclay says nothing okay bj blitz
says
improperly weighted polls by party id
real or not
uh give me a specific poll that you
believe is improperly weighted by party
id
um and then we can look at it
this is um people asking what this is
we're kind of in a transitional period
it's a liminal phase is the way i would
describe it we are in a liminal phase
between the pre-show and the convention
but
uh just stick with me and you're not
going to miss anything and in fact it
looks like it's about to start right now
thanks to mama rabes and tyle mcn
for subscribing with twitch prime very
much appreciate it you know we already
uh it's only the 19th of the month and
we've already surpassed
july in its entirety on twitch which is
very exciting and i love to see that
um okay bernie sanders what are your
main disagreements with noam chomsky
no bert this user who uh sends me
messages under the name oh hold on a
second looks like it's kamala
everybody it's me kamala so before i go
on stage later tonight i want to talk
about the importance of voting
yes i know many of you plan to vote this
year
but admits the excitement and enthusiasm
for this election
you've also heard about obstacles and
misinformation and folks making it
harder
for you to cast your ballot yes so i
think we need to ask ourselves
why don't they want us to vote
why is there so much effort to silence
our voices and the answer is because
when we vote things change when we
vote things get better right when we
vote we address the need for all people
to be treated with dignity and respect
in our country
so each of us needs a plan a voting plan
joe and i want to make sure you're
prepared
if you text vote to 30330
we'll help you come up with your plan
and remember deadlines and get ready to
vote in your community
so send that text and encourage your
family and friends
to send one too now let's enjoy another
night of
inspiration from around our country
i'll see you a little later tonight and
until then i turn it over to my dear
friend
and tonight's moderator carrie
washington here we go
welcome to night three of the democratic
national convention
i'm honored to be joining you as we
continue to celebrate this
unconventional convention we're going to
be hearing a lot more from senator
harris later i promise
but first when i was in seventh or
eighth grade
we memorized the preamble of the
constitution and i've never
forgotten it the first 15 words of our
constitution are
we the people of the united states in
order to form a more perfect
union we say more perfect
because our union is not without flaws
when our constitution was written women
couldn't vote
black people were considered
three-fifths of a human being
but therein lies the work
no one is perfect nothing is
but it is the striving toward justice
equality and truth
that distinguishes us we fight for a
more perfect union
because we are fighting for the soul of
this country
and for our lives and right now
that fight is real right tonight
we are going to hear from so many
phenomenal women
who are working to help us build that
more perfect union
speaker nancy pelosi secretary hillary
clinton
senator elizabeth warren governor
michelle lujan grisham
we're going to see an incredible
performance from jennifer hudson in a
world premiere performance
from billy eilish we'll meet so many of
the activists and organizers working to
build a more equal more just future
and we're going to hear from our 44th
president
barack obama right that's a long way of
saying this is going to be an
unforgettable night filled with
important voices but
the most important voice we hope to hear
from tonight
is the one we need to hear from most
it's yours
because if we are going to repair the
damage that has been done
if we are going to finally realize the
dream we
the people have to get involved each and
every one of us
is the we you are the we
it's going to be your voice your service
your action that helps us create that
more
perfect union tonight we're going to
talk about where we are
and where we're going on so many
issues important to our future 90
percent of americans
support common sense gun laws because we
need to do more to address the epidemic
of gun violence
let's start there
all right so a number of presentations
as you can hear
planned today we will be hearing from a
former president and almost president
we will be hearing from elizabeth warren
we will be hearing from kamala harris
and i think it's going to be a
very interesting evening if if nothing
else and we will see if anybody has
lighting as pristine as that which bill
clinton had yesterday just one of the
best
uh the gaffer needs to get a promotion
whoever handled that
i see a lot of questions and thoughts
continuing to come in and we will
get right back here uh with with the
next speaker
uh john vucinich says that that guy who
cast your stream
at the republican bar ever send you
video no but let me mention that
i often hear after the fact that people
are watching
the stream in a bar in a restaurant
whatever and sometimes the crowd likes
it and sometimes the crowd doesn't like
it if you are in that situation right
now if you are
if this stream is on in any bars or
restaurants or whatever
please get us video of the scene and
people's reactions are people furious or
people not that would be something i
would be very likely
uh to put up on stream and when the last
time it happened which was a long time
ago it was actually pretty funny
benjamin spiegel's asking about belarus
i i don't wanna
i'm not um comfortable enough that i
know all of the details to really be
able to comment
intelligently and so i prefer not to
comment at all
until i am i am so informed matt chavez
says trying to convert trumpists at this
point in time is absolutely useless
however converting libertarians and
third-party voters can be fruitful what
are your thoughts yeah i think that's
very reasonable uh much much simpler as
well
i would certainly say uh bj blitz
says many on the right claim polls are
wrong because most are improperly
weighted by party id
is this nonsense or is their truth to
any major degree well
so what that means is if a state
has 33 percent republicans and a poll
only gives republican respondents 30
percent weight
they would in that scenario they are
underweighing
republicans by three percentage points
so that's the idea of it is it actually
happening
show me an example uh show me an example
and then i
we we can look at that uh oh my mic is
low some people are saying that's
interesting
i haven't made any changes uh as far as
audio goes let me just go one click up
here
click click click maybe that's a little
bit better i want to make sure people
are
hearing me um jocelyn
council says as you're approaching your
15th anniversary where would you like to
see the david pakman show in five more
years
hosted by someone else with me retired
on a beach how about that
what would people say um we might not
need the show anymore if we fix the
country in the next five years that
would be something very interesting
and claire zeller says hi david
hey claire great to hear from you parrot
killer
says hype it up via twitch and
a lot of people think it's going to take
more than four years to fix the country
i think you're probably right
i think you're probably right jake
goldman asks if i think that viral dress
picture was the dress blue or gold i
don't even remember at this point
i really have no no memory of the actual
color
big thank you to stephen gladney who's
new member number five today
carolyn kintish is new member number six
and luis cortina is new member number
seven which is really a great start
seven's a great number i love the number
seven uh and assad katib
says keep it up let's see what's
happening here as we await our first
major speaker of the evening
done three times but i can't touch
or hug him due to cobit 19.
people tell me that i'm lucky i tell
them we are blessed
i remind them that my son is in a
wheelchair and
unable to feed himself i don't think
deandre feels lucky
when he has to be bathed from head to
toe or gets injections for muscle
contractions
i am in a space of gratitude yes
i can touch deandre i can hold his hand
but the child that i birthed
is not able to live his dreams
and that hurts every day
we're reminded that he may never be the
same
we are not alone in every town across
america
there are families who know what a
bullet can do
that's why i'm a mom who volunteers to
stop
this president trump he doesn't care
he didn't care about the victims after
parkland
las vegas or el paso
i want a president who cares about our
pain
and grief a president who will take on
the gun lobby to ban
assault weapons and close the loopholes
to keep guns
out of the hands of criminals joe biden
has taken on the nra twice and won so
just a quick note
i don't think it's a bad idea to address
the issue of guns
we know from polling that it is not a
major issue in this
election so i think it needs to be done
carefully and strategically
lost your children to gun violence it's
not a major voting issue what i mean the
top three are
coronavirus the economy and race
relations
five school shootings
and i made each of them a promise and
made myself a promise
i promise them and i promise all of you
i will make this promise today
those families hurting across the
country i will never
never never never give up this fight
out of pain we choose to find meaning
a glimmer of light that lands on a
promise
former congresswoman gabby giffords
shot in the head from less than three
feet away i remember it
but she survived when tragedy strikes
we seek comfort in knowing we aren't
alone join
us in this fight we seek strength
to keep fighting to keep moving
we turn to leaders who share our pain
in the most difficult times it's when we
stand closest together
it's out of tragedy that we go stronger
he was there for me he'll be there for
you too
we are a nation ready to end gun
violence
a safer america is possible
but from this point forward we must
choose
courage i've known the darkest of days
days of pain and uncertain recovery
confronted by despair i've summoned hope
confronted by paralysis and aphasia
i responded with grit and a termination
i put one foot in front of the other
i found one word and then i found
another
my recovery is a daily fight but
fighting makes me stronger
words once came easily today i struggle
to speak
but i have not lost my voice
america needs all of us to speak
out even when you have to
fight to find the words we are at a
crossroads
we can let the shooting continue or
we can act we can protect
our families our future we can vote
we can be on the right side of history
we must elect joe biden
he was there for me he'll be there for
you
too join us in this fight
vote vote vote thank you very much
imagine you're a member of congress just
out in an event
some lunatic nut shoots you in the head
next thing you know
you'll be lucky if you ever speak again
i mean just just
insane we're facing covet 19
structural racism police violence
against black bodies
violence against members of the trans
community we are facing
so many challenges to meet these
challenges
we will need systematic solutions we
need leaders who can see
us hear us represent us
all of us to joe biden
nothing is more important than taking
the time to make sure that
people are seen heard
and believed in
i was interning in dc and i
remember i called my grandmother and i
said joe biden's walking by
and she goes oh my god oh my god put him
on and i see his staffer going like no
no no like don't don't take the call
what are you doing
and he he points to a staff and he goes
like like go that way and he sent his
staffer away
how could i not be endeared to him
instantly
he talked to me for the next half hour i
see dana bash from cnn there
and she says like senator biden will be
on him like five
and he sends her away he asked me about
my sons he asked me about what i did
all i know was it was all about me
not about him and then he comes back to
me then and goes it was lovely talking
to your grandmother
and then he starts the interview with
dana bash it was unbelievable
i must interject one thing at the very
end of his chat with me he said could
you do me a favor
i said sure what is it he said tell me
how i can get your grandson's hair
[Music]
he was good humor he was sensitive
okay so we're getting into some of these
more ancillary moments as we await the
next
uh speaker i will read a few
messages that have come in uh tro1150ng5
says gabby giffords is more coherent
than trump yeah well said
driedmangos asks should bill clinton
have spoken
since his link to epstein uh trump's
president guys
okay trump's president so clearly that's
not the standard that we go by
aaron mcclay says with trump trash
talking fox recently do you think he may
be angling to buy or start a media
company that competes with fox should he
lose
certainly certainly a possibility and
sophie faraday
says you're live right now but youtube
doesn't show you is live that's sketch
uh yeah i don't um i i don't know much
about that
but clearly people are finding the
stream no youtube does show me as live
as live on
on my uh when i just searched so i think
that that
is certainly happening let's see if now
it is time for the next speaker or if it
will be more
no it is not it's matthew from arizona
okay
so we will we will stand by uh as things
continue to come in uh zion says
rest in peace michael brooks i didn't
realize how much he meant to me until he
was gone
isn't that a common story let's keep him
in our thoughts
left is best all right zion very very
nice i appreciate the message
um i do want to say thanks to
marion sosa who is new member number
eight today at joinpackman.com
remember we are targeting 50 new website
members and then the phones will open
it'll be like magic
not like it'll be like magic the virus
will just leave
no it'll be like magic the phone lines
will just open
and it's going to be incredible it's
going to be truly incredible
over on twitch g-money rider sends me
the message
keep up the good work d-man thank you i
appreciate that
good evening america i'm michelle lujan
grisham governor of the great state
of nuevo mexico i'm proud of my home
state
every single day especially how we have
punched above our weight in our
successful response to covid19
yes i'm proud of new mexicans from taos
to truth or consequences
who have stepped up and sacrificed in so
many incredible ways
this past half year and i'm proud how we
embrace
our multicultural identity as our
greatest strength
and i'm proud that new mexico has shown
what climate leadership looks like
while the trump administration has been
eliminating environmental protections
we've expanded them while they've been
rolling back regulations on oil and gas
we've taken on polluters and held them
accountable
we've committed to a renewable energy
future with exciting and fulfilling
careers
for workers all across our beautiful
strait including
right here in the heart of northern new
mexico we're laying a road map here for
what america can
and should look like in the 21st century
in america where we lead again
where we build safer cleaner and more
affordable cities and communities
where we provide meaningful
opportunities for workers
and families to thrive and build better
lives
as president joe biden will rejoin the
international climate agreement
and the united states will once again
lead on this critical issue
at home he'll invest in energy workers
and he will deliver for working families
across the u.s
helping them build meaningful careers
while accelerating our nation
and world into a clean green 21st
century
and well beyond we know time is running
out to save our planet
we have the chance this november to end
two
existential crises the trump presidency
and the environmental annihilation he
represents
we have the chance this november to
attack the climate crisis
invest in green 21st century jobs and
embrace the clean energy revolution
our country our young people are crying
out for and the leadership
the rest of the world is waiting for the
choice
is clear the choice is joe biden
thank you america there's uh the new
mexico governor
hard work rising to a challenge
the american way going to the moon
was all three the eagle has landed many
astronauts returned home
and reported a shift in their awareness
the view they saw of earth from space
was profound the world looked beautiful
tiny fragile our atmosphere
is all that separates us from oblivion
we now call what they experienced the
overview effect
here in detroit and our communities for
such a long time have faced the burden
of pollution okay a lot of you with a
lot of different messages
coming in wallace derekot asks whether i
have thoughts on john ossoff's chances
of winning the senate seat in georgia
i mean listen the polling is not looking
great but it's worth fighting
it's worth fighting for that that would
be an amazing win
brian p says sam cedar trolls are coming
in force tonight stay safe out there
david i'm not noticing anything
but again i'm also not paying attention
so that may be a factor techie studios
says hey david i'm thinking
to run for a local office position what
advice would you give keep up the great
work as usual oh that's so vague i mean
listen i i think
uh the only knowing nothing else the
only advice i could really give is make
sure that it's a position
uh that that you're not just running to
run but you're running for a particular
reason that that's the position for you
with a goal as to what is it that you're
looking to do what can you bring to it
um that others maybe would not or could
not
and um but beyond that it's tough to
tough to say
too much more we are almost
25 of the way through night three
of the democratic national convention
we'll still be hearing from
nancy pelosi elizabeth warren hillary
clinton kamala harris and barack obama
um all upcoming and we will certainly
not miss
a second a second of those speeches
um we are live on youtube twitter and
twitch and i'm so glad that that people
are joining today
mr robbins says david we are being
evacuated all over california as you
speak
if the climate crisis is humanity's
biggest threat
it is why is the left so quiet i don't
see the left quiet about it
so i don't i just don't agree claire
zeller asks
about my thoughts on laura loomer
winning a primary in florida
uh ominous time for our country would be
my reaction
nato jenkins tv has beautifully gifted
five subscriptions over on twitch black
white rook has also grabbed one
and donkey show has subscribed
uh sarah stein says can we get jon
stewart on the roster i was at his rally
and if there is anyone who can get us
motivated where is he i would love to
see jon stewart speak here
bayfoto would love for someone to point
out that the chaos in the streets that
trump talks about isn't biden's america
it's trump's america yes bay photo
you're right and i've been trying to
make this point
donald trump is running against biden by
saying it's
chaos in the streets re-elect me wait
hold wait why would
if if the chaos is bad don't we want to
change what that doesn't really make any
sense now trump's argument is
oh well it's because the chaos is in
democratically run places
okay it does doesn't seem to bear it out
let's take a listen to what's going on
ali i could hardly breathe i'm alexandra
v senor and i've been organizing young
people around climate change since
2018. here it is climate change is
impacting us now
and it's robbing my generation of a
future for young people my
age every aspect of our lives from where
we go to school
to what kind of careers we'll have to
whether or not we can raise a family
depends on us taking climate change
seriously right now
joe biden won't solve this crisis in
four years no one can
but he will put us back on track so that
my generation can have a fighting chance
i'm asking you to join us don't let our
futures go up in flames
the corn growers near my parents farm
have a saying knee-high by the fourth of
july
these days they're lucky if the corn is
even planted because of unpredictable
and torrential spring rains
i'm andrew adamski i studied microbial
ecology at northern michigan university
us farmers can see the effects of
climate change happening right in front
of
us so we've been trying to do our part
we're adopting sustainable solutions on
my family's farm
switching to a community model using
less land and reusing our resources to
grow
our food we're eliminating tons of
carbon pollution every year by mimicking
natural ecosystems
farmers can be part of the climate
solution instead of a problem
today we all can grow our own future but
we need our leaders to be part of the
solution as well
instead of part of the problem we need
them to commit to the science not ignore
it
we need them to put real plans on the
table rather than roll them back
that's what joe biden is doing with his
clean energy revolution
instead of being left behind we could
lead the world again
i spend a lot of time talking about
climate change with different
communities here in nevada
and the one question that i get asked
over and over again is
what are you doing here not a lot of
climate activists look like me
my name is catherine lorenzo i'm an
afro-latina
and i'm a climate activist i grew up in
a low-income neighborhood
where pollution rates are often higher
than wealthier areas
and a lot of kids have asthma switching
to renewable energy would mean cleaner
air
better health and a steadier income for
folks in neighborhoods like mine
because solar pv installers and wind
turbine techs are some of the fastest
growing jobs in the country
and joe biden's plan is transformative
he knows that saving the planet isn't
just a challenge to overcome
it's an opportunity for a better way of
life
so it's gonna be america are you ready
to vote for joe biden
are you ready to solve the climate
crisis because our futures depend on it
[Music]
okay like the folks we just heard from
next up is another activist and
environmentalist not to mention an
immensely
talented artist she worked to ensure
that her most recent concert tour was
green and sustainable
urging her fans to take similar actions
in their daily lives
and even before she herself was old
enough to vote she held registration
drives before her shows
signing up thousands of voters she's a
voice for her generation in both her
music
and her activism here to perform my
future publicly for the first time wow
billy eilish
huge
you don't need me to tell you things are
a mess
donald trump is destroying our country
and everything
we care about we need leaders who will
solve problems like climate change and
kovid
not deny them leaders who will fight
against systemic racism and inequality
and that starts by voting for someone
who understands how much is at stake
someone who's building a team that
shares our values
it starts with voting against donald
trump and
for joe biden silence is not an option
and we cannot sit this one out
we all have to vote like our lives and
the world depend on it
because they do the only way to be
certain of the future
is to make it ourselves please register
please vote
i can't seem to focus
do we want the music or do we want do we
want messages from you guys
[Music]
to
all right we'll go with it
[Music]
i'll do new member thank you's over
jambo is number nine
i should have a backing track all the
time in life
[Music]
barbara dennis number ten
do you understand alexander morehouse
rome is number
11.
[Music]
chris trent number 12. wow it's so laid
back
[Music]
never had such laid-back member
announcements
[Music]
thanks grumpy house for the sub not with
anybody else high energy
[Music]
i need more people
[Music]
cause you're so handsome
[Applause]
i like the baseline and the drumming
solid
is anthony fantano going to destroy me
[Music]
now
with my future
but not with anybody here
i'll see you when i'm
[Music]
beautiful well done
i'm kind of liking day three this isn't
bad
billy eilish thank you
okay now we're going to talk about
something close to my heart
oh okay the black community in this
country
is hugely diverse on my father's side i
am descended from african americans
who came from slave ships that landed in
south carolina
and who were part of the great migration
north that has played such a defining
role in who we are as a nation
on my mother's side my grandparents came
here as immigrants
part of a rich history that has also
defined america
they immigrated to this country from the
west indies through ellis island in the
1920s
i often think about how my grandmother
must have felt
when she first saw the statue of liberty
in her raised
torch my family's story is not unique
unless you're native american your
family likely came here from somewhere
else whether it was five years ago or
200 years ago
whether it was by choice or by bondage
etched into the dna of who we are as a
nation
is the very idea that though you may be
from somewhere else
you can find your home here
but that idea is in danger now
more than ever before
tell me okay um we will then go back to
the next uh
major major event of of day three um
a bunch of different people sending me
messages sean quillin says via super
chat which you're consider yourself
invited by the way to send a super chat
if you're watching on youtube
keep up the good work shout out to
shaleeah
love it cameron bali david saint george
jennifer cross and patrick standish are
jumping in
daryl haynes liked the music saying the
song is rockin
chris hollis says the duet with david
sang memberships in the background is
amazing
the dude was a big fan of the mellow
david energy
michelle bennett said don't
underestimate billy eilish i don't think
anybody was
i don't think anybody was uh doing that
um
okay so people people generally seem to
like that i think that that's
uh i think that that's great is there uh
i'm trying to think
were there other performances oh okay
yeah jennifer hudson and prince royce
excellent all right i i probably am
partial to prince royce between these
two
myself i don't know if that's going to
be a problem
from the standpoint of everybody bailing
on my stream but i have to tell you
okay um
okay violet violeta caro has sent me a
spanish
super chat spanish saying hola david
that's hi david
people didn't know salud para
de parte de my
greetings from my parents victor and eva
no no
missionaries we never miss your show
they don't speak english
communicate
okay so she's translating and she sent
me a cameo
which for some reason has not come in so
far but okay that's that's okay
no big deal um
okay things are continuing uh a few
other people to say
thank you to jan concepcion
is new member number 13 today bill
keeler
is number 14. john erickson is 15
and matthew vermalin is number 16
16 is a nice number i like it also
jamaica whitsetter has grabbed
a youtube subscription and three on
speed has subscribed with twitch prime
so yes
english and spanish messages are
acceptable
others i can't really say too much of
really
anthony says stoked on you david wanted
to donate say i love you to my wife
sitting next to me watching this
she has no clue okay anthony's wife
anthony loves you or am i supposed to
say i love her i don't i'm not sure i
get it but it sounds like a lot's going
on at anthony's house
and erado says love the show david
here's to one day ridding our system of
big
money donors and lobbyists and then a
very special moment
over on twitch donkey show has gifted
13 13 subscriptions
if you can imagine that but donald trump
took away my ability
to apply for the program trabajamos duro
salimos
we work hard we contribute to our
community and we pay our taxes
i've gone to school and built a good
life for me and my two daughters
i want to go to law school i want to
help my community
but ever since donald trump was elected
all our freers have returned
we don't know if our family will be
separated will my mom and sister be
detained
will my sister get the health care she
needs and deserves i don't have the
right id
so i can't get health insurance through
the exchange
i need health insurance i deserve it
it breaks our hearts to see children
separated from their families at the
border
that's wrong those children need their
parents on november 3rd i'm going to
vote for my mother my sister and my
daughters
i will vote for a future where all of
our lives have dignity and respect
we need a leader who will fix the broken
immigration system
and commit to keeping families together
i'm voting for joe biden and kamala
harris the daughter of immigrants
who are you going to vote for estamos
[Music]
there's something unique about america
yes
we don't simply welcome new immigrants
we are born of immigrants that is who we
are
[Music]
immigration is our origin story
after all unless your family is native
american
[Music]
all of our families come from someplace
else
[Music]
these new americans we see our own
american stories
life in america was not always easy
there was discrimination
and hardship and poverty but like you
they no doubt found inspiration in all
those who had come before them
and they were able to muster faith that
here in america
they might build a better life and give
their children something more
the tension throughout our history
between welcoming or rejecting the
stranger it's about more than just
immigration
this is not the meaning of america
what kind of country do we want to be
immigrants are the teachers who inspire
our children they're the doctors who
keep us healthy
they're the engineers who design our
skylines and the artists and the
entertainers who touch our hearts
immigrants are soldiers sailors airmen
marines coast guardsmen who protect us
we can never say it often or loudly
enough
immigrants and refugees revitalize and
renew america
it's not something to take for granted
something to cherish and to fight for
god bless you may god bless the united
states of america
well put together
[Music]
yeah music yes no what do people say are
we just doing music
[Music]
should i do new members again during
music
no when the night has
[Music]
edwin webb is number 17.
shauna moreno is number 18.
scott schiltz who's number 19.
carl lamarck you are number 20.
robert
[Music]
wow a lot of people are furious i can't
tell
[Music]
are people mad at me
[Music]
leonardo
[Music]
[Music]
and people just don't know how to behave
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
someone just sent me a super chat saying
what was it
uh it was insane chris h says i'm voting
for trump
thank god for him oh my god seek help
chris please
how do you get through the day honestly
i don't know why this is happening
either whenever you're in trouble
[Music]
don't forget to vote this november
together we can make a change jealous
having
no style
let's go there we go
that was prince royce amazing shout out
to the boogie down bronx in this next
piece you'll hear about the vital role
that women have played in moving us
toward a more perfect union
and breaking through that proverbial
glass ceiling and after that
you'll hear from secretary hillary
rodham clinton a woman who put over 65
million cracks in it
[Music]
okay so just minutes remaining before
former secretary of state hillary
clinton
is going to be speaking um simple zack
says via twitch from the standpoint of
independent progressive media i
thoroughly enjoy your elements of your
content very strongly cheers man
appreciate that thank you so much a lot
of super chats coming in the super chat
somebody like somebody opened up a fire
hose and is just
wasting water i guess daniel cohen says
hi pacman i appreciate your sober and
thoughtful progressive approach thank
you for everything
victor sanchez says i'm hispanic stop
the music well so am i my friend
by the way oh i you know i did a segment
about how
i think i filled out the census
incorrectly like it was surprisingly
tricky the way it was worded
and ultimately i i i actually believe
now that the way i should be filling out
the census
is on the question of hispanic
regardless of race
the answer is yes i was born in
argentina
to an argentinian family grew up
speaking spanish
so i believe i'm a yes on hispanic
regardless of race
and then i think asian is actually my
race in the sense that
ashkenazi jews are 11 people
which last i checked is asia so
i think that um i think i'm
an i'm an a hispanic asian essentially
i i know this sounds completely nuts but
this is actually not a joke i read a
very interesting article about it
and i'm certainly not
european in the sense richard spencer
thinks about europeans those are the
europeans that were oppressing me for
2000 years so that wouldn't make any
sense
that would whitewash the history of of
anti-semitic oppression
so if we are going to divide things up
in this way
i think i'm hispanic and asian
it's crazy i know and i know people
think i'm kidding but i'm really not
it's that's the weird thing
uh sabrina zafar says pulling an
all-nighter at work you are the only
thing getting me through by the way if
somebody clips that that could be a
problem for me
but send it to me if you do andrew fox
sings says elements of content
david saint george says i'm irish
catholic and russian jewish i wonder if
that qualifies me as a real american
maybe i should be shipped back to galway
or nava zabirsk i never know how to
pronounce that
al wreck says watching from iraq
stick with it david this is a global
fight thank you i appreciate that
great to hear um
robert seidel sent a super chat asking
for people to hate on chris
h okay that's that's aggressive
galway galway okay i guess i'm not
really sure how the the right
pronunciation is there
thanks to raul monreal who is new member
number 23 today
and monica bailey who is new member
number 24
we are now just moments away from
hillary rodham clinton's presentation
um and i think it's going to be very
very interesting
michelle bennett says bad karaoke music
does no justice to great vocals
maria carolina ferreira says i'm from
brazil so i'm not supposed to like david
because of the argentinian thing but
here i am keep it up no
no no no no we don't do that's not i
don't like the sound of that at all
um something very strange is happening
on my phone i don't know if it's legal
but uh there's megan repino i thought it
was rapino but i was
schooled very strongly um
no i okay well i'm gonna have to put
aside the whole thing about
asian jewish and all of that stuff
people people are getting confused it's
really not a joke
i think you guys need to research it
it's really a whole it's a whole thing
okay moments now from hillary clinton
the audience continues to build
yesterday we actually had a big drop off
right around this time
so hopefully we can keep building the
audience the dnc audience
is bigger it's at a hundred thousand
yesterday at this point it was only
about 65
so seems to be more interest today than
we've seen before
um brian p says
as a heterosexual male how do you
feel about being wholly ignored by the
radical debt
left dems asking on behalf of the trump
trolls in the chat
thank you man i don't even understand
that
sarah mascara says been with you since
the early days thank you for making me
feel sane my pleasure
really my pleasure i'm glad to be here
corey dadbeard has subscribed
at tier one on twitch kyle
neepkins says would you do a deep dive
into a local issue
i'm interested in an analysis of the
education gap
in minneapolis from an informed left
perspective that might it might be a
little too micro
might be a little too micro for our show
but i would
be glad to evaluate the story
uh okay i believe it is time
people are ready for hillary for lack of
a better term let's see
new hairstyle okay the lighting again
beautiful after the last election
beautiful i said we owe donald trump an
open mind and the chance to lead
i meant it every president deserves that
and trump came in with so much set up
for him
a strong economy plans for managing
crises including a pandemic
yes we democrats would have disagreed
with him on many things
but if he had put his own interests and
ego aside
seeing the humanity in a child ripped
from her parents at the border
or a protester calling for justice or a
family wiped out by natural disaster
that would have been a good thing for
america and the world
i wish donald trump knew how to be a
president
because america needs a president
right now live throughout this time of
crisis americans keep going checking on
neighbors
showing up to jobs as first responders
hospitals
grocery stores nursing homes yes it
still takes a village
and we need leaders equal to this moment
of sacrifice
and service we need yes
it still takes a village and we need
leaders
equal to this moment of sacrifice and
service
we need joe biden and kamala harris
everyone has a story about joe's caring
and empathy
i remember him calling after my mother
dorothy died and we talked about
being raised by strong women the best
testament to joe is how he's cared for
his family and how great
is it that dr jill biden plans to keep
teaching as first lady
and joe picked the right partner in
kamala she's relentless in the pursuit
of justice and equity
and she's kind when her press secretary
tyrone gail was dying of cancer she
dropped
everything to be with him in his final
moments
i know something about the slings and
arrows she'll face and believe me
this former district attorney and
attorney general can handle them all
so this is the team to pull our nation
back from the brink
but they can't do it without us for four
years people have told me
i didn't realize how dangerous he was i
wish i could do it all over
some of us were making that pretty clear
four years ago
look this can't be another woulda coulda
shoulda election
if you vote by mail request your ballot
now and
send it back right away if you vote in
person
do it early become a poll worker
most of all no matter what vote
as michelle obama and bernie sanders
warned us
if trump is re-elected things will get
even worse
indeed that's why we need unity now more
than ever
remember back in 2016 when trump asked
what do you have to lose
well now we know quite a bit health care
our jobs
our loved ones our leadership in the
world
and even our post office
but let's set our sights higher than
getting one man
out of the white house joe biden and
kamala harris
are going to give us so much to vote for
let's vote for the jobs that joe's plan
will create
clean energy jobs to fight climate
change
caregiving jobs with living wages vote
for emergency relief that lifts small
businesses
and saves hard-working people from
foreclosures and evictions
it's wrong that billionaires got 400
billion dollars richer during the
pandemic while millions
lost their 600 a week in extra
unemployment
vote for the parents and teachers
struggling to balance children's
education and safety
and for health care workers fighting
covet 19 with little help from the white
house
vote for paid family leave and health
care for everyone
for social security medicare and planned
parenthood
vote for dreamers and their families
vote for law enforcement
purged a racial bias that keeps all our
streets safe
vote for justice for george floyd
brianna taylor and ahmad arberi
because black lives matter vote for
honest elections
so we not a foreign adversary choose our
president
vote for the diverse hopeful america we
saw in last night's roll call
and don't forget joe and kamala can win
by 3 million votes
and still lose indeed take it from me
so we need numbers overwhelming so trump
can't sneak
or steal his way to victory like i've
said text
vote three zero three three zero to get
started
a hundred years ago yesterday the 19th
amendment to the constitution was
ratified
it took seven decades of suffragists
marching
picketing and going to jail to push us
closer to a more perfect union
55 years ago john lewis marched and bled
in selma because that work was
unfinished tonight i'm thinking of the
girls and boys who see themselves
in america's future because of kamala
harris
a black woman the daughter of jamaican
and indian immigrants and
our nominee for vice president
this is our country's story breaking
down barriers and expanding the circle
of possibility
and to the young people watching don't
give up on america
despite our flaws and problems we've
come so far
we can still be a more just equal
country with opportunities
previous generations could never have
imagined
there's a lot of heartbreak in america
now and the truth is many things were
broken before the pandemic
but as the saying goes the world breaks
everyone and afterward many are strong
at the broken places that's joe biden
he knows how to keep going unify and
lead
because he's done that for his family
and country
so come november if we're strong
together
we'll heal together we'll redeem the
soul and the promise
of our country well maybe we'll start
led by president
joe biden and vice president kamala
harris
tonight is a night steeped in women who
have stepped into service
okay so we'll see who's coming up next
but there is hillary clinton
uh chris hollis just notified me via
super chat that he switched his vote
from trump to biden harris after
becoming a member of the david pakman
show of course my last name is
spelled p-a-k-m-a-n but i still
appreciate it
um kmb reminding us
hillary clinton did win the popular vote
by three million votes yes that's true
caleb davis says his wife is feeling the
fallout of the goodyear boycott she
works for a goodyear company and she is
watching please send words of
encouragement caleb's wife
uh i wish i could tell you exactly what
there is right now to be optimistic
about from the standpoint of this
goodyear thing
uh the more likely outcome is
that um trump's gonna forget about it
and he's gonna move on to something else
and things will be okay at goodyear
that's my instinct and that is my
sense uh but let's i wish i had
something
a little more specific uh thanks also to
justin d winters for the support over on
twitch
um robert seidel says this is for my
apolo
this is for my apology for aggression i
just can't handle ignorance
that's okay robert robert's sending some
shots across the bow
at some of our own super chatters and
viewers but that's okay
we are here on almost about to enter
the second hour of day three of the
democratic national convention
looks like just minutes from hearing
from nancy pelosi
nancy pelosi pelosi pelosi i'm a mother
of five grandmother of nine
i know a temperature
the power of the speaker is awesome
that's a good line
[Music]
i know what temper tantrum
[Music]
if you want to go into the arena you
have to be prepared
to take a punch but you also have to be
prepared
to throw a punch right the
[Applause]
throw a children for the children
from running the house to speaker of the
house
and taking on the white house
unapologetic
unafraid madam
[Music]
i'm not a big pelosi fan but i like the
way this video is put together
[Music]
and now please welcome speaker of the
united states house of representatives
my honor
readings of house democrats problematic
most of the worst majority in history
more than 60 women people of color and
lgbtq
our diversity is our strength our unity
is our power
this month as america marks the
centennial of women
finally women struggling a little bit to
speak i'm worried with 105 women
in the house proudly 90
are democrats to win the vote women
marched and fought never gave in
we stand on their shoulders charged with
carrying forward the unfinished work of
our nation advanced by heroes
from seneca falls to selma to stonewall
four years ago when president obama and
vice president biden were in the white
house
they made us proud and their leadership
made our country great
in that spirit we come together now not
to decry the darkness
but to light a way forward for our
country
that is the guiding purpose of house
democrats fighting
for the people we have sent the senate
bills for lower health care costs for
bigger paychecks
for cleaner government protecting john
lewis's voting rights
and enacting george floyd justice and
policing act
we've sent the senate bills to protect
our dreamers lgbtq equality to prevent
gun violence
and to preserve our planet for future
generations
and even more all of this is possible
for america
who was standing in the way mitch
mcconnell
and donald trump our nation
faces the worst health and economic
catastrophe in our history
more than 5 million americans are
infected by the coronavirus
over 170 000 have died
the science-based action the heroes act
we enacted three months ago
is essential to safeguard lives
livelihood
and the life of our democracy and who is
standing in the way
mitch mcconnell and donald trump instead
of crushing the virus
they're trying to crush the affordable
care act and it's pre and
pre-existing conditions benefit
as speaker of the house i've been i've
seen firsthand donald trump's disrespect
for facts
for working families and for women in
particular
disrespect written into his policies
toward our health and our rights
not just his conduct but we know what he
doesn't
that when women succeed america succeeds
and so we are unleashing the power of
women to take our rightful place
in our national life by championing a
woman's right to choose and defending
roe v
wade securing safe and affordable child
care
preserving social security and passing
equal pay
for equal work who's standing in the way
mitch mcconnell and donald trump so here
is our answer
we will remember in november when we
will elect joe biden
president whose heart is full of love
for america
and rid the country of trump's heartless
disregard
for america's goodness joe biden's faith
in god gives him the courage to lead
jill biden's love gives him the strength
to persevere
joe biden is the president we need right
now battle tested forward-looking honest
and authentic
he has never forgotten who he is
fighting for
and kamala harris is the vice president
we need right now
committed to our constitution brilliant
in defending it
and a witness to the women of this
nation that our voices
will be heard our mission is to fight
for a future equal to the ideals of our
founders
our hopes for our children and the
sacrifices of our veterans
our brave men and women in uniform and
their families
we'll increase our majority in the house
we will win a democratic majority in the
senate
we will elect kamala harris vice
president and we will elect
joe biden president of the united states
of america
god bless you and god bless america
okay thank you speaker pelosi
the house is the people's house i
thought hillary was a little better to
to be perfectly frank with everybody um
i give you i don't need to necessarily
say more about that
if you are voting early
or absentee i would love to hear
where you are and how your ballot
request
process has gone you can let me know if
you're watching on youtube
certainly via super chat i would love to
see what people are up to
as far as ballots are concerned
ali says billy eyelash 2024
spread the word pacmeme gang
zac giannikos has says
covid19 denial has me pessimistic about
the climate and the impending global
energy crisis
how are we going to solve a crisis that
will span decades well it'll span more
than that
uh it's going to span more than that in
in all likelihood
um what else do we have matt glynn says
new member mate number 25 g'day from
sydney too
actually i have a few people to say
thank you to
oh boy things are getting crazy hannah
chapman is number 25.
louis everhart is number 26. kiko
omar white is number 27. robert
mccormick you are number 28.
sarah nugent number 29
joshua horner is number 30 and raquel
cretelli is number 31.
what an evening what an evening it is
night three of the democratic national
convention
we have heard from hillary clinton we
heard from nancy pelosi
we heard from prince royce as well as
billy eilish we are still we heard from
governors tony evers and michelle
grisham we heard from gabby giffords
we are still waiting for jennifer hudson
senator kamala harris and former
president barack obama since we only
have an
hour left i am i oh since we still have
a full hour left but only three major
speakers remaining i'm guessing we are
going to have
some longer pre-produced packages and
presentations coming our way
culminating i would guess with barack
obama although maybe
uh kamala harris is going to be the last
person but yeah there's going to be some
filler for sure
in the next 60 minutes if you were just
joining us on
youtube facebook or
uh twitter oh no youtube got shut down
i'm sorry facebook got shut down
because of the musical content we
we triggered a uh some kind of thing
with the copyright oh boy okay
well that's not so good but we're still
going strong
on youtube and twitch if you are
watching on youtube please make sure to
hit the subscribe button you'll be
notified
in the future when i go live make sure
you're following
on twitch if you were watching there a
window zombie requested absentee ballot
in minnesota got primary ballot within a
couple days
mailed it before the election counted on
election date haven't received
general yet laura curiel
somerville massachusetts received my
ballot monday dropped it off at city
hall today go ed markey
t cos wisconsin just got my ballot
application today
very nice kjv says hey david hoping to
call in later about this but my mom is a
centrist on the fence about voting for
joe
since the kamala pick how can i persuade
her well i assume she's not an idiot
because you seem to have a good head on
your shoulders so i'm sure she'll come
around
deity says hey from australia please
vote and don't give us another four
years of nonsense also
not sure why universal health care is
considered radical
in the u.s yes that is a very fair
question tasty fiery funk
and bibi bok choy have subscribed with
twitch prime
donkey show and waxwell are gifting
subscriptions on twitch like there's no
tomorrow francisco resto says i was
going to vote absentee
but i cannot trust the post office so i
will be voting early in person
in person voting starts on october 24th
here yeah remember that the rules for
early
are different in every state and it's
important to know
how early when where usually
it's limited polling places you can find
all of that information um i believe on
vote.org
there's a page an entire page about
early voting which you could check out
um okay
people want to hear something about
what's going on let's listen
at the time the police considered
domestic violence something
that was not a crime in the home it's a
private matter
and so women were responsible for their
own injuries
i was about to say no i don't know
i can only guess how how
how painful that is growing up our
father said that the greatest
of all sins was the abuse of power
he told us when a bully when someone
bigger or stronger
takes advantage of you that is a really
grave sin
the expectation was for all four of us
be a person of character
[Music]
if you see something wrong we were then
expected to stand up and do something
about it
when joe introduced the legislation few
believed it could pass
our bill is an ambitious undertaking it
is the first attempt to address
violent crimes against women it was hard
to get the votes because you had some
traditionalists who just didn't believe
that there should be laws about this but
joe
doesn't give up he's tenacious joe
persevered and he's very good at
persuasion they're doing nothing to help
him
nothing he brought together law
enforcement prosecutors
advocates and survivors thank you for
giving me the opportunity to come and
speak
in 1994 the violence against women act
became law
and protected millions of american women
a lot of the change
in the attitudes we have about domestic
violence were shaped by his leadership
on this
if you see something wrong we were then
expected to stand up
and do something about it
if you're just joining us welcome coming
up we're going to hear from president
barack obama
and senator kamala harris who will talk
about the biden
harris vision for the future but in
order to get to that more perfect union
we have to acknowledge where we are
today
in america we are struggling
unemployment has skyrocketed and
families are fighting to keep their jobs
as joe biden says we need to build back
better
to find out how you can join that effort
please text
join to 30330 to get plugged into this
campaign
and to get more information on how to
vote and how to volunteer
joe biden has a plan to help working
families and small businesses
our next speaker hilda solis worked
alongside him as secretary of labor
to make sure that there were good
american jobs and that americans were
safe
on the job to hear more about the biden
harris economic plan
please welcome gilda solis
okay hello i'm hilda solis
the day vice president biden swarming in
as secretary of labor
was one of the proudest moments of my
life
my parents realized they had achieved
their american dream
because the daughter of two blue-collar
immigrants
would make history and give voice to
people just like them
american workers need a fighter now more
than ever
and joe biden is that person because he
has done it before
and i've seen it firsthand he and
president
obama made it easier for home care
workers to organize
they extended overtime pay to more than
4 million
workers they saved the automobile
industry and a whole lot of good
union jobs with it and when millions of
families lost their homes
my friend from california senator kamala
harris
took on the big banks and won but
because of donald trump's failures
we must once again rescue a sinking
economy
millions of americans are out of work
and communities of color
are the hardest hit millions of
essential workers are putting their
lives at risk
with little protections and millions
more are just
plain tired that's why joe biden
and kamala harris actually have a plan
not only to recover what we lost but to
improve upon it
to build back better creating
5 million good union jobs by bringing
back supply chains
to america that's building back better
creating millions of jobs by investing
in clean
energy that's building back better and
making sure that working families
can afford child care that's how we
build back
better so let me borrow and slightly
edit something
joe biden said at my swearing-in
when it comes to expanding the economy
for all people
no one no one is going to be a stronger
voice
than our next president joe biden
the conversation you're about to see
proves it
every business there's a story small
businesses around the country are
bearing
okay so still two big speakers scheduled
kamala harris and barack obama
so many people want to weigh in on how
they will be voting we are
that's the question among anything else
that i've asked
via super chat um brett de green
says i live abroad turns out arizona
offers email
ballot opportunity uh that sounds weird
i've never heard of that
soto solution full says bernie sanders
only voted for biden's crime bill
because of domestic violence component
wonder why getting votes were so hard
andrea larson washington state is all
mail-in but i'll be delivering it
personally this election to avoid
getting it lost in the mail yeah i plan
to drive my ballot over to city hall
quite frankly uh just to be absolutely
sure
tristan michelle asked me to keep an eye
on trump's twitter just did
david adams says washington state has
automatic mail in voting for me
uh and i think that gets me caught up
um great grebo peter danan rob seidel
get trump out and speed bones have all
subscribed or gifted subscriptions
over on um uh twitch
this is the same person who tweets under
the name or sends messages under bernie
sanders from the standpoint of charlotte
churning the elements of ideas how much
is the reuben reported propaganda
delivery system for far-right extremism
i don't know jose says david did you
know rush called harris a hoe
uh yes yes i did know that
a few other thank yous that i would like
to offer eric deggies
is new member number 32 tonight mark
grad
is number 33 kavika knight is number 34
and diego obeso is number
35 um very very
special things happening at
joinpakman.com
luis everhart asks de gusta la bachata
not so much felicidade portugal
voting from oakland harris's hometown
will drop my ballot at the courthouse so
the elections
office gets it yeah i know more and more
people who are planning to do that
um i i understand why i mean we just at
this point with what's going on with the
mail
now now louis de joy is saying he's not
going to do anything else to the mail
but what they've done may already be
enough
i i think we just you know we just got
to be careful
just if you can drive your ballot over
to or walk it over
to a ballot box i don't think that
that's an altogether
bad idea and i understand exactly
why people are planning to do it i'm
planning to do it i'm planning to
do it uh okay
let's see what else we have going on
here
uh oh i did miss uh andre de haan
who is new member number 36 today
let's tune back in here as we are
realistically moments away from the next
big speaker
salvador we don't ask for much
from government but catch us when we're
falling
and i know that it must feel like you're
falling right now without a net
restaurants are among the hardest
businesses
to succeed at but i was going to do it
in a way that was going to provide
a successful career for not only myself
but 100 employees
this is the story of dan reiner he's a
fifth generation farmer
struggling to keep his business alive
i'm not so sure the president
understands that when he thinks about
business i don't think he thinks about
farmers
no as a business no he has no clue about
this stuff
dan tell me a little bit about the farm
we've been here since 1864.
trade tariffs with china have just been
horrible part of the language in the
trade deal
said that china does not have to buy
unless the price is to their advantage
what kind of trade deal is that that's
no deal
then when covet hit then everything just
plummeted getting through now
that's the problem that's the day-to-day
battle
i believe that joe biden will be a clear
voice for
us something that we have not had joe
biden
has an understanding of what the average
american
is experiencing i think he's with me
enough is enough
it's time to help small businesses
middle class folks manage their way
through a pandemic
i have a lot of confidence in joe biden
he's a fighter and he's the real deal
we've taken a lot of knock downs and
we know that at the end of the day we
will endure we will rise again
every time i get knocked down i got to
get up and keep running keep going
keep going
who's next elizabeth warren
tonight we've heard from the people who
make america work
people who put their lives on the line
to keep our country going and
since covet 19 hit they've taken one
gut punch after another and what is the
coveted fallout done to our babies
well i'm here at the early childhood
education center
in fieldfield massachusetts which has
been closed for months
you're my old stomping childcare was
already hard to find before the pandemic
and now
parents are stuck no idea when schools
can safely reopen and even fewer child
care options
the devastation is enormous and the way
i see it
big problems demand big solutions
now i love a good plan and joe biden has
some
really good plans plans to bring back
union jobs in manufacturing and create
new union jobs in clean energy plans
to increase social security benefits
cancel billions in student loan debt
and make our bankruptcy laws work for
families
instead of the creditors who cheat them
these plans reflect a central truth
our economic system has been rigged to
give bailouts to billionaires
and kick dirt in the face of everyone
else
but we can build a thriving economy by
investing in families and fixing what's
broken
joe's plan to build back better includes
making the wealthy pay their fair share
holding corporations accountable
repairing racial inequities and fighting
corruption
in washington let me tell you about one
of joe's plans
that's especially close to my heart
child care
as a little girl growing up in oklahoma
what i wanted
most in the world was to be a teacher i
loved teaching and when i had babies and
was juggling my first big teaching job
down in texas
it was hard but i could do hard
the thing that almost sank me child care
one night my aunt b called just to check
in
and i thought i was fine but then
i just broke down and started to cry i
had tried holding it all together but
without reliable
child care working was nearly impossible
and when i told aunt b i was going to
quit my job
i thought my heart would break and then
she said the words that changed my life
i can't get there tomorrow
but i'll come on thursday and she
arrived with
seven suitcases and a pekingese named
buddy and stayed for 16 years
i get to be here tonight because of my
aunt bee
i learned a fundamental truth nobody
makes it on their own
and yet here we are two generations of
working parents later
and if you have a baby and don't have an
aunt b
you're on your own and here's why that
is wrong
we build infrastructure like roads and
bridges and communication
systems so that people can work
that infrastructure helps us all because
it keeps our economy going
it's time to recognize that child care
is part of the basic
infrastructure of this nation its
infrastructure for families
joe and kamala will make high quality
child care affordable for every family
make preschool universal and raise the
wages of
every child care worker now that's just
one plan
but it gives you an idea of how we get
this country working
for everyone donald trump's
ignorance and incompetence have always
been a danger to our country
coveted 19 was trump's biggest test
he failed miserably
today america has the most coveted
deaths in the world
and an economic collapse both
crises are falling hardest on black and
brown
families millions out of work millions
more trapped in cycles of poverty
millions on the brink of losing their
homes millions of restaurants and stores
hanging by a thread this crisis is
bad and it didn't have to be this way
this crisis is on donald trump
and the republicans who enable him on
november 3rd
we will hold them all accountable
so whether you're planning to vote
wearing a mask or vote by mail please
take out your phone right now and text
vote to three zero three three
zero clear and crinkly we all need to be
in the fight to get joe and kamala
elected
and after november we all need to stay
in the fight
to get big things done
we stay in this fight so that when our
children and
our grandchildren ask what we did during
this
dark chapter in our nation's history
we will be able to look them squarely in
the eye and say
we organized we persisted and we won
and we changed america
okay very not bad president barack obama
has said that choosing joe biden to be
his vice president
was one of the best decisions he ever
made and this is a man
who has made a lot of good decisions
making health care more affordable and
accessible rescuing our economy
protecting american jobs
marrying michelle obama and through it
all
joe biden was by his side except for
maybe marrying michelle
you can witness their mutual respect and
affection in this clip
take a look all right now building to
obama's speech it looks like
so joe for your faith in your fellow
americans
for your love of country and for your
lifetime of service that will endure
through the generations
i'd like to ask the military aide to
join us on stage
for the finals president
i am pleased to award our nation's
highest civilian honor
the presidential medal of freedom
is trump going crazy
no he's not
[Applause]
and
[Applause]
and for
[Applause]
for the first for the first and only
time in my presidency i will bestow this
medal with an additional
level of veneration on honor my three
most recent successors
reserved for only three others pope john
paul
ii president ronald reagan and general
colin powell ladies and gentlemen i am
proud to award the presidential medal of
freedom
with distinction to my brother joseph
robinette biden jr
will the aide please read the citation
vice president joseph r biden jr
in a career of public service spanning
nearly half a century
vice president joseph r biden jr has
left his mark on almost every part of
our nation
fighting for a stronger middle class a
fairer judicial system
and a smarter foreign policy providing
unyielding support for our troops
combating crime and violence against
women leading our quest to cure cancer
and safeguarding the landmark american
recovery and reinvestment act from
corruption
with his charm candor unabashed optimism
and deep and abiding patriotism joe
biden has garnered the respect and
esteem of colleagues of both parties
and the friendship of people across the
nation and around the world
while summoning the strength faith and
grace to overcome
great personal tragedy this son of
scranton
claymont and wilmington has become one
of the most consequential vice
presidents in american history
an accolade that nonetheless rests
firmly behind his legacy
as husband father and grandfather
a grateful nation thanks vice president
joseph r biden jr
for his lifetime of service on behalf of
the united states of america
if you could raise the camera three feet
it would be great
[Applause]
all right here we go good evening
everybody
as you've seen by now this isn't a
normal convention
it's not a normal time weird angle here
too so
tonight i want to talk as plainly as i
can
about the stakes in this election
because what we do these next 76 days
will echo through generations to come
i'm in philadelphia where our
constitution was drafted
and signed it wasn't a perfect document
it allowed for the inhumanity of slavery
and failed to guarantee women and even
men who didn't own property
the right to participate in the
political process
but embedded in this document was a
north star that would
guide future generations a system
of representative government a democracy
through which we could better realize
our highest ideals
through civil war and bitter struggles
we improved this constitution to include
the voices of those
who'd once been left out and gradually
we made this country
more just and more equal
and more free the one
constitutional office elected by all of
the people
is the presidency so to minimum we
should expect a president
to feel a sense of responsibility for
the safety and welfare
of all 330 million of us
regardless of what we look like how we
worship who we
can happen how much money we have or who
we voted for
but we should also expect a president to
be the custodian of this democracy
we should expect that regardless of ego
ambition
or political beliefs the president will
preserve
protect and defend the freedoms and
ideals that
so many americans marched for went to
jail for
fought for and died for
i have sat in the oval office with both
of the men who are running for president
i never expected that my successor would
embrace my vision
or continue my policies right
i did hope for the sake of our country
that donald trump might show some
interest
in taking the job seriously
that he might come to feel the weight of
the office right
and discover some reverence this is
building democracy
that had been placed in his care
but he never did
for close to four years now he has shown
no
interest in putting in the work of
course no interest in finding common
ground
no interest in using the awesome power
of his office
to help anyone but himself and his
friends
no interest in treating the presidency
as anything but one more reality show
that he can use
to get the attention he craves someone's
gonna have to explain this speech to
trump
donald trump hasn't grown into the job
because he can't
that's right and the consequences of
that failure are severe
death for many 170
000 americans dead right
millions of jobs gone well those at the
top taken more than ever
our worst impulses unleashed
our proud reputation around the world
badly diminished
and our democratic institutions
threatened like never before
now i know that in times as polarized as
these
most of you have already made up your
mind
but maybe you're still not sure which
candidate
you'll vote for speak to them or whether
you'll vote at all
speak to them especially maybe you're
tired of the direction we're headed but
you can't see a better path yet or you
just don't know enough about the person
who wants to lead us there we know
plenty
so let me tell you about my friend joe
biden
12 years ago when i began my search for
a vice president
i didn't know i'd end up finding a
brother
joe and i come from different places
different generations but
what i quickly came to admire about
joe biden is his resilience born of too
much struggle
his empathy born of too much grief
joe is a man who learned early on to
treat
every person he meets with respect and
dignity
living by the words his parents taught
him no one's better than you joe
but you're better than nobody
that empathy that decency
the belief that everybody counts
that's who joe is
when he talks with someone who's lost
her job joe remembers the night his
father sat him down to say
that he'd lost his
when joe listens to a parent who's
trying to hold it
all together right now he does it as a
single dad who took the train back to
wilmington each and every night
so he could tuck his kids into bed
when he meets with military families
who've lost
their hero he does it as a kindred
spirit
the parent of an american soldier
somebody whose faith has endured the
hardest loss
there is
for eight years joe was the last one in
the room whenever
i faced a big decision he made me a
better president
and he's got the character and the
experience to make us
a better country and in my friend
kamala harris he's chosen an ideal
partner
who is more than prepared for the job
someone who knows what it's like to
overcome barriers and who's made a
career
fighting to help others live out their
own american dream
along with the experience needed to get
things done joe and kamala
have concrete policies that will turn
their vision of a better
fairer stronger country into reality
they will get this pandemic under
control like joe did when he helped me
manage
h1n1 and prevent an ebola outbreak from
reaching our
shores they'll expand health care
remember two people died of ebola trump
called for obama's resignation
helped craft the affordable care act and
nailed down the votes to make it the law
they'll rescue the economy like joe
helped me do
after the great recession i asked him to
manage the recovery act
which jump-started the longest stretch
of job growth in history
and he sees this moment now not as a
chance to get back to where we were
but to make long overdue changes so that
our economy
actually makes life a little easier for
everybody
whether it's the waitress trying to
raise a kid on her own or the shift
worker
always on the edge of getting laid off
or the student
figuring out how to pay for next
semester's classes
joe and kamala will restore our standing
in the world and as we've learned
from this pandemic that matters
triggered joe knows the world
and the world knows him
he knows that our true strength comes
from setting an example
that the world wants to follow a nation
that stands with democracy
not dictators a nation that can inspire
and mobilize others to overcome threats
like climate change and terrorism
poverty
and disease
but more than anything what i know
about joe what i know about kamala
is that they actually care about every
american
and that they care deeply about this
democracy
they believe that in a democracy
the right to vote is sacred and we
should be making it easier for people to
cast their ballots
not harder
they believe that no one including the
president
is above the law and that no public
official
including the president should use their
office
to enrich themselves or their supporters
they understand that in this democracy
the commander-in-chief
does not use the men and women of our
military who are willing to risk
everything to protect our nation as
political props
to deploy against peaceful protesters on
our own soil
they understand that political opponents
aren't un-american just because they
disagree with you
a free press isn't the enemy but the way
we
hold officials accountable trump doesn't
think so that our ability to work
together to solve big problems like a
pandemic
depend on a fidelity to facts and
science and logic
and not just making stuff up
none of this should be controversial
these shouldn't be republican principles
or democratic principles they are
american principles
but at this moment this president
and those who enable him have shown
they don't believe in these things
tonight i'm asking you to believe in joe
and kamala's ability to lead this
country out of these dark times and
build it back better
at least as a start but here's the thing
no single american can fix this country
alone
but one american descent
democracy was never meant to be
transactional you give me your vote i
make
everything better it requires an active
and informed citizenry
so i'm also asking you to believe in
your own ability
to embrace your own responsibility as
citizens
to make sure that the basic tenets of
our democracy endure
isn't it because that's what's at stake
right now
our democracy
look i understand why
a lot of americans are down on
government
the way the rules have been set up and
abused in congress make it easier
for special interests to stop progress
than to make progress
believe me i i know it i understand
why a white factory worker who's seen
his wages cut or his job shipped
overseas might feel like
the government no longer looks out for
him
and why a black mom might feel like it
never looked out for her at all
i understand why a new immigrant might
look around this country and wonder
whether there's still a place for him
here
why a young person might look at
politics right now
the circus of it all the meanness and
the lies
and conspiracy theories and think
what is the point 60 million voted for
it
well here's the point 60 million will
again
and those in power those who benefit
from keeping things
the way they are they are counting on
your cynicism
they know they can't win you over with
their policies
so they're hoping to make it as hard as
possible
for you to vote yes and to convince you
that your vote does not matter
that is how they win that is how they
get to keep making decisions that affect
your life
and the lives of the people you love
that's how the economy will keep getting
skewed to the wealthy and well connected
how our health systems will let more
people fall through the cracks
that's how a democracy withers until
it's no democracy at all
slowly and we cannot let that happen
do not let them take away your power
do not let them take away your democracy
make a plan right now for how you are
going to get involved and vote
i'm bringing my ballot as early as you
can and your family and friends how they
can vote too
do what americans have done for over two
centuries when faced
with even tougher times than this
all those quiet heroes who found the
courage to keep marshy
keep pushing in the face of hardship
and injustice
last month we lost a giant of american
democracy
in john lewis and some years ago i sat
down with john
and a few remaining leaders of
the early civil rights movement
one of them told me he never imagined
he'd walk into the white house
and see a president who looked like his
grandson
and then he told me that he had looked
it up
and it turned out that on the very day
that i was born
he was marching into a jail cell
trying to end jim crow segregation in
the south
what we do echoes
through generations
whatever our backgrounds we are all the
children of americans who fought the
good fight
great grandparents working in fire traps
and sweatshops without rights
or representation farmers
losing their dreams to dust the
triggering
irish and italians and asians and
latinos told
go back where you come from
jews and catholics muslims and sikhs
made to feel suspect for the way they
worshipped
black americans chained and whipped
and hanged spit on
for trying to sit at lunch counters
beaten for trying to vote
if anyone had a right to believe that
this democracy did not work
and could not work would have been john
lewis it was those americans
our ancestors they were on
the receiving end of a democracy that
had fallen short
all their lives
they knew how far the daily reality of
america strayed from the mid
and yet instead of giving up they joined
together
and they said somehow some way we are
going to
make this work we
are going to bring those words in our
founding documents
to life
i have seen that same spirit rising
these past few years
folks of every age and background who
packed city centers and
airports and rural roads so that
families wouldn't be separated
so that another classroom wouldn't get
shot up
so that our kids won't grow up on an
uninhabitable planet
americans of all races joining together
to declare
in the face of injustice
and brutality at the hands of the state
that black lives matter no more
but no less so that no child in this
country
feels the continuing sting of racism
to the young people who led us this
summer telling us
we need to be better
in so many ways you are this country's
dreams fulfilled
earlier generations had to be persuaded
that everyone
has equal worth for you it's a given
a conviction
and what i want you to know is that for
all its messiness and frustrations
your system of self-government
can be harnessed to help you realize
those convictions for all of us
you can give our democracy new meaning
you can take it to a better place
you're the missing ingredient the ones
who will decide whether or not america
becomes
the country that fully lives up to its
creed
that work will continue long after this
election
but any chance of success depends
entirely
on the outcome of this election
this administration has shown it will
tear our democracy
down if that's what it takes for them to
win
it is what it takes and they will do we
have to get busy building it up
by pouring all our efforts into these 76
days
run up the score and by voting like
never before
literally for joe and kamala and
candidates up and down the ticket
so that we leave no doubt about
what this country that we love
stands for today
and for all our days to come
stay safe god bless
excellent speech from former president
barack obama
thank you triggering donald trump for
your thank you for your brilliant
leadership
hugely tricky joe biden has chosen an
extraordinary woman
to be his running mate kamala harris is
a fighter
and a trailblazer using her
groundbreaking ideas to protect families
and
keep them together by reducing
recidivism
i am so thrilled for her to become
the vice president of the united states
now please welcome our convention chair
congressman benny thompson all right so
standing by now for kamala harris who
will be the last
speaker of the evening um
[Music]
super chats just pouring in people with
so much to say
people are gifting subscriptions people
are destroying their computers throwing
their cell phones into the trash going
absolutely crazy by what we are seeing
here
uh we we did hit uh 10
000 live youtube viewers during the
barack obama speech
we will see if there is even more
interest and uh in in kamala harris's
speech
upcoming um people asking me about
video game trailers we're not doing that
right now meanwhile so barack obama just
spoke
at the dnc next week that couple who
pulled guns out when protesters walked
by their houses in saint louis will be
speaking at the republican national
convention
right so you understand very very
different
situations um and we will presumably
presumably uh soon hear from kamala
harris
with her perspective on what is at stake
here
and what is upcoming and we are going to
oh also
the kid from covington will be speaking
at the rnc
and the kids trump's children who he
doesn't hate
and has a relationship with so i guess
tiffany trump won't
be there at all um
sebastian boulis suggested barack obama
should have been the vp pick
i think it would have been problematic
uh in terms of optics although
i would have been interested in it
samara khatib says obama should have
worn a tan suit to annoy hannity
i would have liked to see it by what
design says obama sounding like yang
right now i don't know about that robert
seidel says am i the only one that
misses this man i'm 45 and white and i
believe he was
maybe not the best but a great president
wixy bits says the only work trump did
was on his
golf swing very well said very well said
a good opportunity now to get your
potentially final super chats of the
evening in as we stand by
for the last moments here
uh johanna garber is new member number
37
on my website joellant joshi is number
38.
peg farrar is number 39
and peter hawley is new member number 40
today what a beautiful round number
40 i uh enjoy it very very much
scott hack says from st louis all of
saint louis hates them they are
litigious jack wagons
robert seidel says stay tuned for kamala
kamala just minutes away expecting her
to probably go over
11 p.m here on the east coast they've
been going over by a few minutes each uh
each evening maybe by design quite
frankly
from the standpoint of uh intruding on
the
11 pm news on the east coast typical
strategy
that uh people often
adopt during such events um
okay let's get ready for kamala harris
she is the first black woman first south
asian woman to be named on the
democratic team this is a historic
picture
someone who looks like us on a
presidential ticket that's
crazy kamala harris is us
she was born in oakland the daughter of
immigrants
the daughter of chandler
big sister and protector she
is oh by the way i'm being told that
twitch is running some kind of
60 off subscriptions thing and that this
is like
the best time in the history of twitch
to subscribe i don't really know
anything about it
but messages are just pouring in people
are churning this idea of 60
off 60 off so just something to think
about
i'm thinking about it very strongly
right now
40 off i don't know something it sounds
illegal to me
when she says for the people it is
she's for us she's for us she fights for
women's rights
she fights to end mass incarceration she
is a fearless
advocate for the voiceless the litmus
test for america
is how we are treating black women now
i'm talking about someone who can fight
for black people
brown people undocumented people lgbt
people
disabled people young people old people
all
of america it's about all of us knowing
our power
each of us to lift people up right
that's twenty percent
that's not so good we see them and we
hear them and that they matter
[Applause]
[Music]
are you going to be vice president of
the united states
oh this is interesting greetings america
is that a green screen
it is truly an honor to be speaking with
you tonight
that i am here tonight is a testament to
the dedication
of generations before me women and men
who believed so
fiercely in the promise of equality
liberty and justice for all
this week marks the 100th anniversary of
the passage of the 19th amendment
and we celebrate the women who fought
for that right
yet so many of the black women who
helped secure that victory
were still prohibited from voting long
after
its ratification but they were
undeterred
without fanfare or recognition they
organized and
testified and rallied and marched and
fought
not just for their vote but for a seat
at the table
these women and the generations that
followed
worked to make democracy and
opportunity real in the lives of
all of us who followed they paved the
way
for the trail blazing leadership of
barack obama and hillary clinton
and these women inspired us
to pick up the torch there's like
security but there's no crowd it's weird
women like mary church terrell mary
cloyd bethune fannie lou hamer and diane
nash
constance baker motley and the great
shirley chisholm
we're not often taught their stories
but as americans we all stand on their
shoulders
and there's another woman whose name
isn't known
whose story isn't shared another woman
whose shoulders i stand on and that's my
mother
shamala gopalan harris
she came here from india at age 19
to pursue her dream of curing cancer
at the university of california berkeley
she met my father donald harris
who had come from jamaica to study
economics
they fell in love in that most american
way
while marching together for justice in
the civil rights movement of the 1960s
in the streets of oakland and berkeley
i got a stroller's eye view of people
getting into what the great john lewis
called
good trouble when i was five my parents
split
and my mother raised us mostly on her
own
like so many mothers she worked around
the clock
to make it work packing lunches before
we woke up
and paying bills after we went to bed
helping us with homework at the kitchen
table and shuttling us to church for
choir practice
she made it look easy though it never
was
my mother instilled in my sister maya
and me the values that would chart
the course of our lives she raised us
to be proud strong black women
and she raised us to know and be proud
of our indian heritage she taught us
to put family first the family you're
born into
and the family you choose
family is my husband doug
who i met on a blind date set up by my
best friend
family is our beautiful children cole
and ella
who call me mamala family is my sister
family is my best friend my nieces
and my god children family is my uncle's
my aunts
and my chitties family is mrs shelton
my second mother who lived two doors
down and helped raise me
family is my beloved alpha kappa alpha
our divine nine and my hbcu brothers and
sisters
family is the friends i turned to
when my mother the most important person
in my life
passed away from cancer and
even as she taught us to keep our family
at the center of our world she also
pushed us
to see a world beyond ourselves
she taught us to be conscious
and compassionate about the struggles of
all people
to believe public service is a noble
cause
and the fight for justice is a shared
responsibility that led me
to become a lawyer a district attorney
attorney general and a united states
senator
and at every step of the way i've been
guided
by the words i spoke from the first time
i stood
in a courtroom kamala harris
for the people i have fought for
children
and survivors of sexual assault i fought
against
transnational criminal organizations i
took on the biggest banks
and helped take down one of the biggest
for-profit colleges
i know a predator when i see one
my mother taught me that service to
others
gives life purpose and meaning
and oh how i wish she were here tonight
but i know she's looking down on me from
above
i keep thinking about that 25 year old
indian woman
all of five feet tall who gave birth to
me
at kaiser hospital in oakland california
on that day she probably could have
never imagined that i would be standing
before you now
and speaking these words
[Music]
i accept your nomination for vice
president
of the united states of america
i do so committed to the values
she taught me to the word that teaches
me
to walk by faith and not
by sight and to a vision
passed on through generations of
americans
one that joe biden shares
a vision of our nation as a beloved
community
where all are welcome no matter what we
look like
no matter where we come from or who we
love
a country where we may not agree on
every detail
but we are united by the fundamental
belief
that every human being is of infinite
worth
deserving of compassion dignity
and respect a country
where we look out for one another where
we rise
and fall as one where we
face our challenges and celebrate
our triumphs together
today that country feels distant
donald trump's failure of leadership has
cost
lives and livelihoods
if you're a parent struggling with your
child's remote learning or you're a
teacher
struggling on the other side of that
screen you know
what we're doing right now is not
working
and we are a nation
that is grieving grieving the loss of
life
the loss of jobs the loss of
opportunities
the loss of normalcy and yes
the loss of certainty
and while this virus touches us
all we got to be honest
it is not an equal opportunity offender
black latino and indigenous people are
suffering and dying disproportionately
and this is not a coincidence it is the
effect
of structural racism of inequities in
education
and technology health care and housing
job security and transportation
the injustice in reproductive and
maternal health care
in the excessive use of force by police
and in our broader criminal justice
system
this virus it has no eyes
and yet it knows exactly how we
see each other and how we treat
each other and let's be
clear there is no vaccine
for racism we've got to do
the work for george floyd
for brianna taylor for the lives of
too many others to name for
our children and for all of us
we've got to do the work to fulfill
that promise of equal justice
under law because here's the thing
none of us are free until
all of us are free
so we're at an inflection point the
constant
chaos leaves us adrift
the incompetence makes us feel afraid
the callousness makes us feel alone
it's a lot and here's the thing
we can do better and deserve
so much more we
must elect a president who will bring
something different
something better and do the important
work a president who will
bring all of us together black white
latino
asian indigenous to achieve the future
we collectively want
we must elect joe biden
and i will tell you i knew joe as vice
president
i knew joe on the campaign trail
and i first got to know joe as the
father
of my friend so joe's son
beau and i served as attorneys general
of our states delaware and california
during the great recession he and i
spoke on the phone nearly
every day working together to win back
billions of dollars for homeowners from
the big banks
that foreclosed on people's homes and bo
and i
we would talk about his family how as a
single father
joe would spend four hours every day
riding the train back and forth
from wilmington to washington
beau and hunter got to have breakfast
every morning
with their dad they went to sleep
every night with the sound of his voice
reading bedtime stories
and while they endured an unspeakable
loss
those two little boys always knew that
they were deeply
unconditionally loved
and what also moved me about joe
is the work that he did as he was going
back and forth
this is the leader who wrote the
violence against women
act and enacted the assault weapons ban
who as vice president implemented the
recovery act
which brought our country back from the
great recessions
he championed the affordable care act
protecting
millions of americans with pre-existing
conditions
who spent decades promoting american
values and interests around the world
joe he believes we
stand with our allies
and stand up to our adversaries
right now we have a president who turns
our
tragedies into political weapons
joe will be a president who turns our
challenges
into purpose joe will bring us together
to build an economy that doesn't leave
anyone behind
where a good paying job is the floor
not the ceiling joe will bring us
together
to end this pandemic and make sure
that we are prepared for the next one
joe will bring us together to squarely
face and dismantle racial injustice
furthering the work of generations
joe and i believe that we can
build that beloved community
one that is strong and decent
just and kind
one in which we can all see ourselves
that's the vision that our parents and
grandparents fought for
the vision that made my own life
possible
the vision that makes the american
promise
for all its complexities and
imperfections
a promise worth fighting for
so make no mistake the road ahead is not
easy
we may stumble we may fall short
but i pledge to you that we will act
boldly and deal with our challenges
honestly we will speak truths
and we will act with the same faith in
you
that we ask you to place in us
we believe that our country all of us
will stand together for a better future
and we already are we see it in the
doctors the nurses the home
health care workers and frontline
workers who are risking their lives
to save people they've never met we see
it in the teachers and truck drivers the
factory workers and farmers
the postal workers and poll workers
all putting their own safety
on the line to help us get through
this pandemic and we see it in so many
of you
who are working not just to get us
through
our current crisis but to somewhere
better there's something happening
all across our country it's not about
joe
or me it's about you
and it's about us people of
all ages and colors and creeds
who are yes taken to the streets
and also persuading our family members
rallying our friends organizing our
neighbors
and getting out the vote
and we have shown that when we vote
we expand access to health care
and expand access to the ballot box and
ensure
that more working families can make a
decent
living and i'm so inspired by a new
generation you you are pushing us
to realize the ideals of our nation
pushing us to live the values we share
decency and fairness justice
and love you are patriots
who remind us that to love our country
is to fight for the ideals of our
country
in this election we have a chance
to change the course of history
we're all in this fight you
me and joe together
what an awesome responsibility
what an awesome privilege
so let's fight with conviction
let's fight with hope
let's fight with confidence in ourselves
and a commitment to each other
to the america we know is
possible the america
we love
and years from now this moment will have
passed
and our children and our grandchildren
will look in our eyes and they're going
to ask us
where were you when the stakes were so
high they will ask us what was it like
and we will tell them we will tell them
not just how we felt we
will tell them what we
did thank you
god bless you and god bless the united
states of america
okay vice presidential nominee kamala
harris
i don't think this speech was
as good as barack obama's or hillary
clinton's
um it's a tough situation
the choice to do this sort of big stage
with no people
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
and here is joseph r biden jr
[Applause]
[Music]
please
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
it's tough with this format it's very
[Music]
tough
[Music]
all right night three of the democratic
national convention has come
to an end that is it for tonight
um tomorrow joe biden's speech
as well as a whole bunch of other people
um i will have full coverage reaction
reviews and everything
tomorrow that is going to do it for me
long day tomorrow thanks to everybody
who joined me
we'll see you then
you